Porsche is teaming up with Pixar...
...to create a special one of one car inspired by Sally Carrera.
It's fun because it's come full circle.
We're inspired by the Porsche originally for the movie, Cars...
...and now, that character is inspiring a new physical car.
Sally Carrera in the film was the 2002 911...
...and here we are, 20 years later, creating this new special project.
We get to play car designers when we worked on Cars.
Now, we're actually working with Porsche.
One of our goals was not to create a car...
...that copy pastes from the original one...
...you know, with the eyes and the windscreen and the mouth.
Instead, a real, street-legal, drivable car.
This car is special and whoever has this car...
...will have something unique that will probably never happen again.
For this fundraiser, and being the 20th anniversary...
...for the car that we used in the film for Sally,...
...it's a great opportunity to kind of use this time...
...to give back in the spirit of Sally.